- And we found this story on vogue.com
about Alyssa Bertrand.
And she's a mom of six who
upcycles thrift store finds.
And Alyssa, Alissa, excuse me,
takes clothes, bedsheets,
tablecloths, and curtains
and turns them into insanely
cool children's clothing.
And then she posts it all
on her Instagram account,
Jabellafleur, that's French for flower.
And I am a lifelong
vintage store enthusiast.
I really mean it,
my housewares, my clothes, all my life.
So I really took a shine
to her and her work.
And now, she's here to tell us about it.
Please welcome Alissa Bertrand.
(audience applauds)
- Hi, Drew!
- Alissa!
- I'm so excited to be here.
- Oh, I'm so thrilled.
Okay, I am not kidding,
your work is exquisite.
No wonder Vogue is all over it.
It looks Vogue level!
You have six kids!
- Thank you.
- Tell us about your models.
- So yes, I'm a mom of six,
but on my page, Jabellafleur,
you see my three younger girls,
which is Jayla, Jada, and Ella.
And I design for them
because they still think
it's cool and fun to hang
with mom and take pictures
and to get on and move.
- I mean, this really is, if
this was in the pages of Vogue,
I would not bat an eye.
It's really amazing what you are doing.
And I heard that you liked
going to vintage thrift stores
rather than buying in regular stores.
Why is that?
- Well, it started because, I mean,
I always wanted to be a fashion designer,
but couldn't afford the
name brands and the logos,
and plus, I couldn't
find prints that I liked.
And I'm all about prints
and definitely florals,
the more the merrier.
So I just started
repurposing and thrifting
and finding what I liked
to recreate for the girls.
- What is your trick to photography?
Because, honestly, these
are not iPhone pics.
I don't know what you're taking them on,
but they just look really elevated.
- It is an iPhone. It's an XR.
That's what I have.
I mean, I'm keeping it simple.
- It's an art. And I really am
amazed at what you're doing.
Now, what are your top three
thrifting tips, please?
- Okay, so first, if you see
it and you like it, buy it
'cause it might not be there next time,
and that's a hard one to learn.
Second is just go in and don't
expect to find something.
If you're looking for a Jimi Hendrix,
and you look through 100
shirts and you didn't find it,
you're gonna probably come
out with something else
and still be okay.
And then third, just go
in and search for you
and what you like and
what makes you feel good,
rather than you going
to a department store
and it's being setup.
Try something new.
What's a $4 shirt that has patterns
when you're a neutral person?
Try it.
Because the best thing is,
when you start thrifting,
it's fun and it can be
extremely rewarding.
- I totally agree.
As a lifelong thrifter and
vintage collector myself,
I just always find things I
could never find in a store.
And I must say, your clothes
and pictures are no different.
They're unique and one of a kind,
and we totally celebrate you.
Thank you, Alissa, for being here.
- Thank you so much!
- Thank you so much
for coming on the show!
(upbeat music)